how's it goin man my name is Bob I
shouldn't you brothers know this by now
hey thanks for five minutes by the way
appreciate it I don't know what that was
either stop judging me
okay well [ __ ] dinosaurs I don't know
how the hell we went from poo to
dinosaurs but hey we did it and though
I'm gonna be honest those are not
accurate dinosaurs dinosaurs have waved
back bigger house than that
I mean smaller heads whatever there you
go being Josh well again I don't done
diddly diddly literally they'd look what
I would like we're gonna go here [ __ ]
that temple I say [ __ ] it I don't think
you can literally [ __ ] a temple of it
done diddly look like we can't go there
[ __ ] oh look at these camera angles it's
pretty good okay
okay I'm here I'm here I'm here
everything's gonna be fine right eh
Oh money money money money money money
money what you be where the [ __ ] you
been oh he went grazes on me
that [ __ ] how great kill feel like
Jimmy isn't a ring am I am i wrong with
this I feel like I feel like ginger is
just like whatever and now I offended
three gingers watching my videos
okay I just don't feel like it's racist
to say bad things about gingers it feels
more like just mean in general or the
normal thing to do I don't know anyway
that's a beer with a clubber pup Club
but do you call those clubs in there
whatever you're from we call him who
baklava in Sweden well that guy died
that's good
I mean not if he had a family but if he
was an evil man I think it's good that
he died there you go being judge full
again that time in a video or peer at
bay well what the [ __ ] is going on here
hello whoa are those Mexicans hi mexic I
have no quote those are definitely
Mexicans okay well we don't want to [ __ ]
with Mexicans right now what there's a
chocolate on the rocket what does
chocolate does for care for a Care Bear
Otto well I get that thing again I
wonder if I can use it to go up uh-huh
what is that good for Oh Janey HP on
strikes did you think of that huh that's
a gentle anymore are you
oh man it's it's good man it feels good
to me it it's not the haulage [ __ ]
dead god damn it
well [ __ ] I'm gonna have to kill you now
wait
great well I am clearly with what the
[ __ ] is he saying okay Plan B run for
your life I could lick I can push this
ball first we roll a bowl of poo then we
roll a ball of something else that I
don't remember and now we're rolling a
ball of rock genius genius game playing
no Mexicans why are you so mean oh you
throw up on me that's [ __ ] mess stop
it
come on Cocker come on come come on come
on come on come on come on
conky cool what are you doing don't you
know if you're a Mexican and watching
this I hope you're happy
okay I still like you you have a great
mustache
oh that's why I did that say I know I
was a genius I mean it's obvious but if
I Ashe [ __ ] I log every [ __ ]
run just give it up and die great voice
acting
the rock even had an eye on it that's
wonderful but that's a regular to say
for Kong Kiko what do we have now I dad
looks like a boss battle whoa Oh
the things I do for money [ __ ] that yeah
hey maestro yes
don't you think that's a little bit too
dramatic yeah something with a bit more
epi yeah better that's better
well I did I assume color by hey LaLanne
it's giving me health this is definitely
gun is this a Lion King I feel like this
is the Lion King rip up art there's a
botany ah what did I do
okay so Shambhala but he'll love a great
great lyrics haha and then we drop it by
pressing uh-huh and now what did I do
okay so we're gonna lure the dinosaur
there or whatever the [ __ ] I can just go
here well I'll be done diddly they I'm
darned where the [ __ ] are we now that's
a dinosaur egg isn't it
[ __ ] sneezes man what are you doing
it's that guy from the bar oh he's gonna
be angry
Wow okay I finally realized I'm supposed
to jump on this yeah okay there we go
I got off his stone there wait whoa I
can go up that up I feel like we're
gonna do something stupid rush hashman
ha ha ha ha okay similar some time later
triple odd okay oh oh it's gonna hatch
hey cam come here you're gonna be a mom
ha hello what not that [ __ ] is that
thing oh [ __ ] well that guy got brutally
murdered so he thinks I'm your mom right
what the hell is I like that is wearing
a diaper already mom man
I am yeah like right I'm your mummy come
on follow me I'm a man alright so now
that did thing follows me for because
they thinks I'm his mom that's really
nice
alright I'm going out going without you
man
is he coming yes yes thank God
hello it back yeah Oh Oh all right well
keep following me
uh-huh Dino come here I don't care if
you want a knife on what all right stay
here for one minute
just one minute please for you stay
there for one minute please
one [ __ ] minute all right sorry
camicazi but you will have to die
shut up all right
No why did you move I hate you stay here
for just one minute pop up mama pills
it's gonna be right there I promise
nothing bad is gonna happen to you
you're just gonna [ __ ] it you little
[ __ ] gonna be interesting
baby oh that poor little thing I changed
my mind
ah
I'm solid haha poor little thing
he didn't do anything to deserve that Oh
shet its Chris dashed with your oh wait
he's happy about that
you
oh holy [ __ ] yeah
okay guys that guy again what the [ __ ]
on new album boy those about tomorrow
mm-hmm what what what's going on here
pants is so confusing really don't love
them little oh I'm supposed to jump on
this again how they're supposed to be
money up here right that's my money
Hey another wise guy come on come on
dick
kill ya have that gold card for you
Nellie
well at least Concord has his priorities
set straight let's get friend I saw an
extra life here yeah there it is
give me that [ __ ] 24 [ __ ] please that's
way too much doesn't look like it
Oh pepper okay yeah that works all right
we got pepper in both that should do it
Oh
my ear right in his face that's frigging
icing
oh those special special effects top
touch okay
well hopefully we can actually enter
this [ __ ] now it's a lot of [ __ ]
effort to go in here
Asha but uh by hey Lila gosh um but uh
but uh the sneezes got wonderful only a
little bit here but we can get rid of
that no problema
no problem I said nothing kills me
but we can go in so regardless don't it
lately
yeah what the [ __ ] girls let's go
cha-cha bro-chachos multitouch atcha
all right way keep goin I don't even
care anymore go conky Co I want to be
like you I want to be the very best
squirrel that no one ever works
yeah and I'm Dennis Oh Cashman it's my
real test to train a now hmm take the
kitty whoo cut us badassery sorry Cherie
better Cherie what do I do with this why
do I do I can go to the club please tell
me I can go to nightclub because I
always wanted to go to night Caillou I
found what garden akka I always wanted
to go to like that Danny did a video
game what do we do now hi hi hi
yeah slowest walk ever hey baby
hey 3d
but what is he gonna do it comfy there
oh I'm not I'd like you guys come on oh
[ __ ] oh not these guys again
what do they watch huh
I mean a fight I'd okay okay that was
right once the guys up there uh-huh
you're like no well I don't like the
light
I be getting rid of them dude funny face
huh yes what I tell them
okay guys let me add the first pop oh
yeah first pop and they suck they're
getting murdered
kallab there we go good job my brethren
now get this guy get this guy I hate him
I said no stickers I said I don't give a
[ __ ] uh I think your elephants somehow
what with my friends here yeah yeah yeah
whatever that guy's got yeah I'll flip
this out so what do you say hmm you seem
like my kind of guys okay but I need the
password your mom's a [ __ ]
yeah if you know what the password if
what I feel
Felicia what the Bailey Oh hmm how do
you know that
ha ha ha ha I know everything no cars
I'm quite lovely
did you see the prologue ha ha ha
nothing can we come in yeah
what happen finally we can go to the
nightclub jaysis cries man all right
we're going in the nightclub rich I just
can't [ __ ] away to party oh hi this
I just gotta blend in there man no
problem no problem
why do I do it huh
I got an idea I got night at get drunk
forest and pee on them fine
I uh I gotta pee on these guys what's up
guys got the base good you like a [ __ ]
don't ya
best [ __ ] gaming right there right
there they don't even care [ __ ] I'm so
[ __ ] wasted
hi